diese geschichte beginnt an einem
frühlingstag im april des vergangenen
jahres
sie spielt am vierwaldstättersee und in
der karibik
sie spielt zwischen himmel und erde
zwischen der schweiz und der
dominikanischen republik
es ist die geschichte einer familie und
ihre suche nach dem glück
irgendwo zwischen hier und dort
die geschichte handelt von carlos und
seine freundin manuela müller und von
drei generationen der familie feierabend
das junge paar vertreibt sich die zeit
mit spaziergängen denn bald wird es
soweit sein
sie werden eltern eines kleinen jungen
werden
carlos der schweizer aus der karibik und
manuela die tochter eines eisenbahners
ausziehen
carlos wird heute im kanton uri
genauso wie seine brüder die alle hier
leben sie haben hier arbeit und freunde
gefunden und manchmal treffen sie sich
bei jedem verwandten bei tante lisbeth
und dem konzept hin früheren carlos und
manuela freddy und lange und pappe mit
tatiana tante lisbeth und die man
ersetzen den brüdern ein wenig die
fehlende familie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im untergeschoss von manuelas elternhaus
bewohnt das junge paar eine kleine zwei
zimmern o
carlos und manuela sind sozusagen rund
um die uhr damit beschäftigt sich auf
die geburt ihres kindes und auf das
leben als eltern vorzubereiten
was macht ihr jetzt carlo
wir machen einen weg und ich für uns
was meinst du wie wird sich dein leben
verändern
das kommt nicht von anderen zeit und wir
freuen uns seite nach ein bisschen
nervös ich bin wenig her
wir können auch nicht warten alle hier
und ich haben das rauskommt ist das
etwas vertrauen ihr geträumt hat eltern
zu sein
naja ich holte immerhin fand rebellen
halmich und die wird euer leben
sozusagen als junger held was denkst du
ja weiß nicht aufregen der das wäre was
gehört hausen leben in der zeit des
wartens ist aus kalus so etwas wie ein
künstler geworden er hat damit begonnen
bunte bilder herzustellen bilder die ein
wenig an die naive kunst der karibik
gewinnen
das passt insofern zu kahlos als er
wolle nun schon neun jahre in der
schweiz ist immer wieder von der karibik
träumt und sich auch immer wieder in
diese traumwelt
und flüchtet ich weiß nicht fast muss
noch viel lernen habe ideen habe ich
jetzt die welt räumen
das ist schon gut so nein nicht das
nicht gefunden einfach manchmal da
eigentlich ein fehler
ein ganz herzlicher mensch ein paar tage
später bin ich wieder zurück in der
innerschweiz
manuela hat den kleinen kajo auf die
welt gebracht und carlos ist im
vaterglück ich bin ich habe einen traum
immer noch zeit das erste mal aber nicht
da gekommen weil sie hat so schmelzen
kann doch nicht so richtig erfahren
aber dies
weißt du dein leben wird sich ändern
jetzt verstärkt dass du bist erst jetzt
fängt jungtieren angefangen aber ich
freue mich sehr
was ist anders als jetzt sind wir zu
dritt ja jetzt weiß ich wenn ich nach
hause komme es nicht nur immer neuen als
war auch sonst das baby und es ist
einfach wenn ich von der arbeit kommen
und das manuelle mit dem baby auf mich
warten
[Musik]
mehr
ja
[Musik]
nach ein paar tagen fahren die jungen
eltern und der kleine chor nach hause
kaya der nach dem spitznamen seines
großvaters kari getauft ist
bis mäßig
finde ich eine windhose kennen
den niederrhein gekommen sind so ist nun
die nächste generation angekommen in
dieser schweizerische karibischen
familie und für carlos und manuela ist
das glück perfekt
doch den ersten anlauf zur
familiengründung hat er hat der jüngste
der brüder samuel gemacht
vor zwei jahren hatte er die damals
17-jährige der casado in der karibik
geheiratet die heute mit ihm zusammen in
altdorf lebt
für die junge frau ist es ein weiter weg
wenn sich die beiden unterhalten dann
tun sie das meist auch spanisch und die
gespräche drehen sich oft um die alte
heimat in der karibik irgendwie hier und
doch noch nicht richtig da
und so hatte die geschichte von sami
khedira begonnen
[Musik]
es war an einem nasskalten winter morgen
vor zwei jahren in zürich kloten
als samuel seinen plan in die tat
umsetzte ein tag wie gemacht zur abreise
in die tropen
[Musik]
an diesem tag hatte sich samuel der
jüngste der feierabend brüder auf den
weg gemacht ins land seine mutter in die
dominikanische republik
samuel hatte ein ehrgeiziges ziel er
wollte als erster heiraten
drüben in der karibik wartete seine
braut auf ihn kurz vor weihnachten 2012
sollte die hochzeit sein
[Musik]
samuels reise führt ins hinterland der
dominikanischen republik hinauf in die
berge
dorthin muss ich kaum ein tourist
verirrt hier lebte samuel bis zu seinem
fünfzehnten hartes jahr
es ist eine reise in die vergangenheit
und in die zukunft zugleich denn dort wo
er aufgewachsen ist wartet jetzt seine
branche und das ist sie da er 17 jahre
alt verliebt und verlobt ein
schweizerisch karibisches paar auf der
zielgeraden in die fast ein jahr haben
sie sich nicht gesehen
[Musik]
und was ist er denn so für ein typ will
ich wissen sagt einer er ist schön und
sympathisch
[Musik]
sehr romantisch und sehr gute menschen
bald nach der ankunft gehen die beiden
auf den friedhof
dort liegt samuels vater begraben karl
feierabend dieser war anfangs der 80er
jahre hierher ausgewandert und hatte mit
seiner frau marina vier söhne
[Musik]
[Applaus]
feierabend aus der schweiz starb am 21
februar 2007 mit 62 jahren an einem
herzinfarkt in ranchi arriva in der
dominikanischen republik
[Musik]
in einem einfachen häuschen aufgebaut
war sein tod wie sein leben bescheiden
leise ganz unauffällig verabschiedete er
sich aus dieser welt als wollte er auch
im tod kein weiteres aufheben machen
in den 80er jahren zog es einige
schweizer auswanderer hierher ins café
gebiet der karibikinsel
[Musik]
sie zogen in ein kleines kaff namens
runkeeper in eine landschaft die
manchmal ein bisschen an die schweizerin
dort traf ich vor genau 25 jahren karl
feierabend zum ersten mal was heißt hier
früher kali kompass rot kreuz helfer
haben der in seinem ersten leben für
alle vier akw 17 jahre lang war der
schnapsbrenner mit eigener bereich gern
gesehen
auf allen höfen dann 1982 begann sein
zweites leben
kari taxi haben und in einen container
und verschickte ihn hierher in die
tropen pharma wollte er werden groß
fahren was er hier nur gerade ein paar
gänse statt einer winde hürde vor sich
her treiben würde hatte sich damals zu
hause in rotkreuz nicht träumen lassen
17 jahre lang hatte er gespart über
200000 franken immerhin als startkapital
in der fremde
[Gelächter]
eigentlich liegt oder welle sondern
traurig aber dann ist wie sie mit dem
büro und da ein wenig konsumiert so doch
die dominikanische republik und so hatte
es begonnen
kari schloss sich einer gruppe land
interessenten an und flog auf die
karibikinsel auf vermittlung der
schweizerisch dominikanische
maklergruppe ini besichtigte kari einige
farmen und entschloss sich schließlich
zusammen mit fischli hans aus dem
toggenburg zum kauf einer farm von 93
hektaren 66 davon gehörten kari in einem
achttägigen besuchsprogramm waren sie
durchs land geschleust worden
für nur 50 rappen pro tag könne man hier
taglöhner anstellen wurde versprochen
und bereits am 8 tage hieß es
vertragsabschlüsse in unseren büros
nachmittags frei die glyzinie versprach
bei der bewirtschaftung behilflich zu
sein und schloss mit arealen vertrag ab
die makler kauften dünger und saatgut
versprachen die ernte zu verkaufen und
rechneten die schönen gewinne aus die
dazu machen sein
die bohnen wuchsen zwar durchaus den
gewinnen wurde nichts
kari wahl auf falsche berechnungen
hereingefallen sind sie damit nicht
gläubig sind ja im nachhinein weiß ich
gleich wie clean
nach anderthalb jahren war er pleite
khalifa los ein ganzes land für das er
über 200000 franken hingeblättert hatten
ein lebenstraum in trümmern
[Musik]
zwölf jahre später machte ich mich
nochmals auf die suche nach kali denn
die frage stellte sich warum kehrt einer
wie er pleite wie er war nicht einfach
in die schweiz zurück unter das dach des
sozialstaates
es war nicht schwierig ihn
wiederzufinden
in rancho arriba dem kleinen dorf im
café gebiet wo er genau erlebt sieht man
vom 13
[Musik]
die branche befürchtet
und wenn ja wie denn
wahrscheinlich habe man gesagt trotz
pleite und pech ist kari da geblieben
und auf anhieb käme keiner auf die idee
dass es sich hier um einen ausländer
handelt carli lebt wie ein einheimischer
casino eine mit schweizer fahne
allerdings calli hat sich mit ein paar
tausend franken die ihm nach seiner
pleite von damals übrig geblieben waren
drei hektar und land in der gleichen
gegend gekauft hier lebt er seit elf
jahren aus kleinbauer und irgendwie
wundert er sich noch heute darüber wie
er hierher geraten ist
die dominikanische republik santo
domingo aber nico ist der sendetermin
für die dominikanische republik
das heißt der größten und am abend
trennten sie von santo domingo
[Musik]
obwohl karl komplett pleite war wieder
hier
[Musik]
wieso man einfach zurück die schweiz
juni mit kreuz als im container wieder
braucht zu sein in die hand und hatte
die messe abzusagen
natürlich gibt es noch einen grund
er heißt marina mit ihr lebt caritas in
der schweiz ein eiserner junggeselle war
seit zwölf jahren zusammen in einem
bescheidenen häuschen am rande eines
kleinen grundstücks im laufe der jahre
sind noch viel grüne mehr dazu gekommen
um hier zu bleiben
sami unterton
die schweizer buchen arm aber glücklich
so viel gotthelf gibt es nur noch hinter
karin
großes glück in einer bescheidenen hütte
alles selber gebaut von kari zwei zimmer
und eine küche im schlafzimmer wachen
nebst hiesigen heiligen auch schweizer
ikonen über die hälfe des karibischen
so stehen platz auf drei hektar die
einmal wiese waren ist eine veritable
plantage entstanden
mit zwölf sorten bananen orangen
mandarinen passion fürchten kiwis und
kaffee welche software
[Musik]
aber enrique ja gut
kaffee ist ein unsicheres geschäft kari
lebt mehr schlecht als recht von seinem
kleinen anwesen am café verdiente er
wenn es hochkommt 1000 bis 2000 franken
im jahr
überlebt hat weil es eine schweiß anlage
aus der schweiz mitgebracht hatte er
fliegt alles was ihm die nachbarn
bringen so kommt er auf ein
monatseinkommen von umgerechnet 250 bis
300 franken
er ist so ein fleißiger mensch und er
kümmert sich um die kinder
er ist immer hier er ist sehr häusliche
gegen hauser trinkt nicht nur junge
nicht auf der straße herum ein guter
mann nur ehrlich dieser riesige patin
der schneidet ihn ja nein dieser bank
das gefällt mir nicht immer ehrlich
einfach zum finale im gesicht gestohlen
und betrogen es nämlich der fahren also
von neue immer verloren verloren machen
aber kein unglück nicht los
vier jahre später vier abi caris leben
hat sich äußerlich nicht groß verändert
doch vieles läuft nicht so wie er es
sich erträumt hatte geld wird immer mehr
zur mangelware
versteckte unter bananenstauden hat
karies eine improvisierte
schnapsbrennerei aufgebaut geplante
verschiedene sorten exotischer schnäpse
schwarz natürlich
[Musik]
der trainer von ball an die schnäpse
haben 62 prozent alkohol und schmecken
am besten aus kaffee schnaps mit tropen
und dass ich wie aus dem waschkessel ist
eine funktionstüchtige busch destillerie
geworden
charis kinder gehen in rancho reaper ins
gymnasium dieses werden sie nach zwölf
schuljahren beendet haben und dann
werden sie das gleiche problem haben die
ihr hier
was tun die arbeitslosigkeit beträgt
mehr als 50 prozent und jeder der hier
noch bei trost ist sagt sich nichts wie
weg in ein anderes land in die usa
spanien oder eben in die schweiz
und so kam es denn das am 4 august 2005
alito feierabend in der schweiz eintraf
erwartet von seiner tante lisbeth und
diesem land
deutsch dann khalid fast gar nicht mit
seinem vater hatte elina spanisch
geredet erste verständigung es versuche
so macht der sohn des kali wenn
umgekehrt gewesen sein vater er will
hier arbeiten geld verdienen dass er
seinem vater in die karibik schicken
kann
und er will in der schweiz das werden
was bisher mühsam pass verspricht ein
wichtiger schweizer
düren
ein weiteres jahr ist ins land gegangen
leto lebt sie im frühling im herz der
schweiz sozusagen
er lebt bei seiner tante lisbeth der
schwester seines vaters und jedermann
sap und man hat ihn offensichtlich gern
gekauft was sie gedacht wie lebst du gut
bist du wissen aber macht man nicht
alles für mich nicht wichtig ist so
wenig ist ja viel nachdem er nicht aber
finde ich das kann ich apple läden
aber ich meine es gefällt gefällt mir
genug was gefällt dir dann habe ich in
der schweiz also wenig rechten der
frauen ja kein zufall haben
nicht viel weniger weil er ein bisschen
einsam ist hat er sich 24 einige freunde
angeschafft nino und mahnung
ich kann nicht eine hundehaare haushalt
darf eine rate also wollte ich ein affe
alles muss in afrika kaufen eine halbe
von einen rate und gefällt mir dass das
viele geld das er verdienen möchte in
der schweiz nicht auf der straße liegt
musste gallito schnell lernen
jetzt arbeitet er für 20 franken in der
stunde in der fenster fabrik bündner in
erstfeld wo man grundsätzlich des lobes
voll ist über ihn er macht hier die
erfahrungen eines ganz gewöhnlichen
immigranten einfache arbeit statt
plötzlichen reichtums und er hat er die
lämmer
er ist zwar ein schweizer mit pass aber
irgendwie halten alle für irgendetwas
anderes
ist das hier anders als in der karibik
welch ein anderer was ist der
unterschied sei alles ganz perfekt
machen
milito ist in einer schweiz geraten von
der keine ahnung hatte eine moderne
durch organisierte gesellschaft weit und
breit kein viertes werk
was ist dein größter wunsch als ein
guter wein gute lohn eine schöne haus wo
ich kann meine familie haben auch eine
freundin auch viele kollegen ein
wesentliches liegt in der verschwörung
des schweizers gallito ist natürlich die
sprache
einmal pro woche besuchte den
deutschunterricht in altdorf
also her kam sprache wie gesagt noch
kein wort
und wenn das gegenüber stimmt man sieht
es gleich lernt es sich leichter carlos
sie willst dann so hat er sich leicht
für mich
[Musik]
nach anderthalb jahren erstmals wieder
zurück in der dominikanischen republik
zusammen mit seiner tante lisbeth und
ihrem mann selbst zu besuch beim vater
und beiden brüder
[Musik]
hier ist es wie eh und je
karl i von morgens früh bis abends spät
unterwegs auf seinem kleinen hof drei
hektar montage einkauf eine co2 kehrte
carlito ist für seine brüder so etwas
wie ein vorbild
er hat sich einen computer angeschafft
und zeigte ihnen bilder aus der fernen
heimat schweiz
er ist ihr weg bereitet in die bessere
zukunft denn auch sami freddy und pepe
träumen nur davon dorthin zu ziehen wo
milch und honig fließt also in die
schweiz
lieber heute als morgen macht mit seinem
buben den ganzen haushalt denn seine
ehefrau marina ist wieder einmal weg
dieses mal ist sind spanien wo sie als
putzfrau arbeitet und das einkommen der
familie aufzubessern
eine zeit lang war sie in miami denn wir
wollen es nicht verschweigen auch das
eheglück der feierabend ist nicht mehr
so wie einst im mai
mit dem selbst gebackenem brot bananen
schnaps und käse aus der schweiz fühlt
man sich ein bisschen wie fabrice hüte
eine idylle aufzeigt die frau ist
auswärts und auch die kinder man so bald
wie möglich glück
sonst hatte cani bei solchen
gelegenheiten gerne das lied auf meiner
ranch bin ich könig gesungen
doch heute stand der sinn nach etwas
traurigen nach dem strich ja ja sie ali
und 9.1 täglich weniger kreis und
komitee für tim als tiefstapler peter
stein
[Musik]
am späteren abend ging s carré ganz und
gar nicht mehr gut
er musste in das fast drei stunden
entfernte spital gebracht werden
es wurde in schlecht auf den holprigen
straßen er konnte kaum mehr atmen alles
tat ihm weh
ein wiedersehen alles deutet darauf hin
dass kali einen kleineren herzinfarkt
gehabt hatte und der druck
not only for you be
[Musik]
niemand hätte es gedacht nach einem tag
im spital hatte carey abends um halb elf
einen zweiten herzinfarkt der sofort
tödlich war
[Musik]
ich ganz komisch auf die fans
doch die steico im tv talk mit die
gelenke hängt ein großer tour
beständig und warfen das ist auch gut so
die reduktion auf meiner ranch bin ich
zunächst darauf dass laut drei jahren
vorsieht also da nur verdammt krieg den
sicherungs gesorgt
der hänge dollar
aus der traum
[Musik]
wie war das jetzt ohne den vater ich
wenig gemacht
wie sehen wie schwierig eine wiese bevor
das jahr verabredet für mich gemacht
diese nacht war nicht
die jungs das war ganz komisch gelaufen
bin war das nicht mehr
wie war dein vater hat sie erlebt mit
den kindern
er hat sich hinzugesellt apfel versuchen
die vier buben so etwas wie normalität
herzustellen
so sind sie alleine gelassen der vater
gestorben und die mutter weit weg in
einem vorort von barcelona treffe ich
marina mieter die miete von kari
arbeitet viel als hausangestellte weil
sie kein flugticket und kein geld hatte
konnte sie auch nicht zurück fliegen aus
dem mann starb wie war das als sie hörte
dass er gestorben ist
es war sehr hart
ein harter schlag
ich hätte nie so etwas gedacht
ich dachte wenn ich dorthin zurückkehre
werde ich ihn antreffen wie immer in
saarlouis
nein
nie hätte ich gedacht dass mich ein
solches schicksal trifft
warum arbeitest du eigentlich hier in
spanien
ich wollte hier arbeiten um carrie zu
helfen damit er nicht so viel arbeiten
muss
er war schon älter und ich wollte dass
er was hat und weil ich jünger bin
dachte ich ich könnte mir zum einkommen
beitragen
aber so ist das leben dort wo er jetzt
ist man dort kommt keine zurück wie ist
denn deine zukunft ich weiß es nicht
aber wenn ich arbeiten muss dann tue ich
das um meine kinder voranzubringen
damit ihnen nie etwas fehlen wird muss
man dazu diese ausland ja schon die in
santo domingo gibt es nichts
dort muss man entweder beziehungen haben
oder ein politiker sein aber das gefällt
mir nicht
da gehöre ich nicht dazu wer seine
kinder später in der schweiz leben
das kann durchaus sein
aber das stück land das karree gehört
wird immer unser land
als andenken ankara ein andenken für
immer
wie sehen sie denn deine kinder sie sind
so wunderbar sie sind mit mir wunderbar
und sie waren wunderbar mit ihrem vater
über seinen tod hinaus hat kari für die
seinen gesorgt weil sein bruder in der
schweiz immer brav die ahv eingezahlt
hatte wird marina eine schweizerische
witwenrente bekommen und die kinder eine
waisenrente solange sie in ausbildung
sind
[Musik]
so endete das leben des schnaps brenes
karl feyerabend in der gleichen art wie
alles leben irgendwann endet und es
setzt sich gleichzeitig ford durch die
kinder und kindeskinder nämlich noch
lange erzählen werden von kari wer aus
dem fernen landen ausgerechnet hierher
kam
wo doch alle anderen nichts wie weg
wollen
[Musik]
im fluss des lebens werden nun die söhne
und seine stelle treten ihr eigenes
leben führen ihre eigenen kinder haben
in denen irgendwie auch der autor noch
weiterleben wird im fahrer der
feierabend sieht das nächste kapitel in
dieser unendlichen geschichte so aus
dass am zwanzigsten april 2007 der
jüngste der söhne der 15-jährige sami in
zürich-kloten ankommt
[Musik]
seine tante lisbeth deren eigene kinder
ausgeflogen sind wird sich um ihn
kümmern
[Musik]
lässt sich reparieren
ein weiteres jahr ist ins land gegangen
und sie lebt und auch in früheren bei
seiner tante lisbeth und ihrem mann sepp
doch selbst nachdem er hier ankam
stellte sich heraus dass es bei ihm
ziemlich langsam ging kurz gesagt er
kann sich fast nichts merken wenn er hat
und wieso der jüngst wie sozusagen ihren
bruder mit dem kapital ist jetzt einmal
aus der schweiz sich möglichst
unauffällig brühl tätig ist und alle
drei machen
jetzt hat sich zeigen dass er
behinderte haben wir das ein mensch
braucht es noch vom leben als sprach das
landgericht es auch in sporne scheine
ich als anbieter zeit dass es somit zum
lernen und da hat er zeit aber hat das
beobachtet und riesige fünf studio von
betongold aber fit und darf das um
galopp zeit und daher gesagt ja das
signal der sieger mal mit drei glaubens
gibt und sie bewusstlos und dennis aogo
und hände geschüttelt und das heck ist
und daher jetzt mit waffen
der sieger wiederholte dass eine
effektive körperlicher schaden hat sie
das im dorf oder du versuchst of mormon
dass er einfach lernschwierigkeiten
hetterich serienauftakt und fröhlichen
gebracht worden
kacke am dampfen ist ja gut
morgens um 5 uhr ihn erst fällt wie hat
sie eine stelle gefunden als hilfskraft
beim bäcker roesing noch nie sei er zu
spät gekommen lobt man im smi ist das
fast schon so etwas wie ihr traumberuf
auch zu hause hat er viel gebacken
zusammen mit seinem vater
[Applaus]
außer mehrheit von ihm strahlend so
forsch christen und ich möchte aber auch
studium das kommt für mich am vortag
alle personen und lebensfreude mit
buchstaben und das liegt einfach zweimal
pro woche geht sie in die deutschstunde
im schulhaus vom früheren board wartet
frau wolski auf ihn die im einzel
stunden gibt
da darf man ja nein nein ich denke das
ist gerade nein der ist krank
das junge nach der jungen saison
stopp jetzt hast du etwas vergessen der
junge gesund gesund ist der song gut
jetzt machst du einen stopp jetzt
probieren wir einen satz zu sagen jetzt
was gutes objektiv
die frau ist war naja lassen
das mädchen ist probiert es nochmals
recht brechen ist das ist nicht gut
fröhlich also ich glaube er hat elisa
chance sehr glücklich hier im moment
sich mit druck profi man muss lernen
muss so viel machen dumme gordon mit
drei toten hat für montag ist abgehakt
aber er hat ja nicht um das krank und
sie sicher interessant es war schnell
vergessen und ich freue mich klagt nach
studium zu kommen
und auch das wasser oft betrugs ist er
dank monate her
die zwei indigo wo dann am 21 januar
2008 war es endlich soweit
sami und kalli torwarten zusammen mit
und wies auf die mutter auf marina smi
geht diese lange zeit der einsamkeit zu
ende
[Musik]
wird ja
mit marina kommt freddy der dritte der
söhne von kari jetzt ist nur noch köpfe
in der karibik doch auch er wird bald
hier sein das liegt wie wir nun gemerkt
haben sozusagen in der logik dieser
geschichte
[Musik]
wie geht es dir in modena
ich bin so glücklich sagt sie jetzt habe
ich schon mal ein trio ihren
[Musik]
ja
gestern
meine mutter kommt ja wirklich gut
[Musik]
marina ist fest entschlossen hier in der
schweiz ein neues leben zu beginnen
in wicker schwanden im schächental dort
wo im winter drei monate lang die sonne
nie scheint hat carlito für die ganze
familie eine wohnung gemietet
eine günstige weit ab vom schuss
[Musik]
fünfeinhalb zimmer noch etwas
provisorisch eingerichtet aber immerhin
ein neues zuhause für die familie
wir schauen wir wenig fernsehen sagt
marina obwohl sie die tagesschau noch
nicht wirklich versteht
maria ist stolz und zeigt mir das zimmer
von carlito dass sie ausgesprochen
romantisch findet nein einen solchen
kühlschrank hatte marina die
leidenschaftliche köchin noch nie die
einrichtung bringt die familie an den
rand ihrer finanziellen kräfte ihre
einkünfte aus witten rente und carlitos
lohn liegen um die 4000 franken pro
monat
aber es ist teuer in der schweiz und die
jungen sind den elektronischen
verführungen ziemlich ausgeliefert mit
schweizer franken zu rechnen
das müssen sie erst noch lernen
die eigentliche arbeit hier ja ich
möchte irgendetwas arbeiten
ich frage nicht was mir gefällt ich
suche irgendetwas ich möchte nicht
leicht werden oder so etwas
ich möchte nur etwas zum leben haben und
ich möchte alles was möglich ist für
mich und auch noch etwas mehr damit ich
für die anderen meiner familie sorgen
kann
was kannst du nicht gut also ich kann
ein wenig kochen irgendetwas ich möchte
keine sekretärin sein aber sogar das
würde ich versuchen wenn es sein müsste
wichtig ist einfach etwas zu tun und das
mit liebe nicht nur hier ist freddys
zimmer und hier haben wir alle trophäen
von kari seine medaillen seine kristalle
und so weiter es ist eher wie ein museum
ja genau und hier ist noch seine uhr
die läuft immer noch
[Musik]
kali ist in der wohnung um die präsenz
die bilder an der wand machen die
familiengeschichte zur legende
doch wie wir wissen gab es in dieser ehe
nicht nur eitel sonnenschein wie es denn
so gewesen sei mit karin wollen wir
wissen
auf der einen seite war es gut
und auf der anderen ein eines muss ich
sagen er war fleißig und er war gut zu
den kindern
da fehlte nichts aber es fehlte etwas
anderes mehr fehlte etwas
ich kam zu kurz ich bin doch das
wichtigste aber lassen wir das vor der
kamera aber die zu wenig zärtlichkeit
aber sicher war ja wie der schnee da
draußen zu kalt aber lassen wir das
und du weißt ja wenn in einem haushalt
ein feuer brennt und du kein holz nach
schiebst du weißt du was passiert ja so
war zu wenig für das feuer
ja klar aber wie gesagt er war ein guter
vater das können sie dir bestätigen
könnte es sein dass sie nochmals
heiraten ja sicher ich glaube schon wenn
das leben nie jemanden wunderbares
vorbei schickt nur da aber wenn einer
kommt der diemel nicht los dann lasse
ich es lieber bleiben lieber nichts als
einen der immer säuft streitet 8 oder
große reden führt so einen säufer nein
danke
in altdorf im hotel höflich hat marina
dank der guten beziehungen ihre
schweizer verwalten
eine stelle
putzfrau gefunden die schweizer pass und
ein soziales netzwerk machen das
schicksal der feierabend im vergleich zu
anderen immigranten natürlich ziemlich
leicht abgesehen von der sprache wie
redest du eigentlich mit den leuten mit
händen und füßen sagt marina wie die
stummen reden wir hier oder wie die
kinder im berufsbildungszentrum instanz
besuchs carlito eine ausländer klasse
die auf die lehre vorbereiten soll
hier lernt der frauen deutsch und hier
wollte ich khalid an einem
donnerstagmorgen treffen
doch weit und breit keine spur nur eine
ausrede er sms
es tut mir leid dass ich nicht in die
schule kommen kann
wir sind gestern abend erst um 21 15
nach hause gekommen und heute habe ich
keinen bus was bedeutet dass angekommen
letzte chance weiß ja ich denke dass ich
für ihn ganz schwierig das gilt für die
eine ganz schwierige situation bei
ccesigg das c steht also das kommt
natürlich offen eine arbeit gehabt ob
das kann ich ihnen nicht sagen aber ich
denke ich war richtig die traffic alito
nicht etwa andere arbeit
nein er ist vor der deutschstunde in
seine garage geflüchtet
und hier widmet er sich seinen
wirklichen träumen und bastelt sich
seine zukunft zusammen
und die liegt weit weg vom schattigen
tschechen
dann meldet jeder wo willst du dieses
jahr ausbauen
als wir die augen raus wo sehr viele
optionen fragen sich immer so
das wäre eigentlich das wurde umgesetzt
noch nicht kennt muss nach beispiel
chance darauf machen plötzlich gas und
dort willst du leben ja in zukunft her
der liter das ist offensichtlich richtet
sich ein auf ein leben zwischen zwei
welten zwischen hier wo es arbeit gibt
und dort wo die seele zu hause ist
[Musik]
und so sind wir denn ein weiteres mal
auf dem flughafen kloten
marina wartet
annika leto und seine freundin tanja
waren in der karibik in den ferien wo
bringen jetzt den letzten der brüder
liegt und die schweiz
[Musik]
b
jetzt sind sie alle da nur ein jahr nach
dem tod von karl
marina galic rapper samy und freddy sie
richten sich eine existenz in der
schweiz
doch wahrscheinlich wird sich ihr leben
noch lange zwischen diesen beiden welten
abspielen zu denen sie gehören haub
angekommen irgendwie noch dort aber doch
schon hier
[Musik]
altdorf vier jahre später zeit um die
feier abends wieder zu besuchen
ich treffe sie an einem überraschenden
ort im fitnesscenter good life wo
zumindest fred ipo carlos regelmäßig
trainieren
die feierabend söhne irgendwie sind sie
immer noch unterwegs zwischen diesen
beiden welten zu denen sie gehören jedes
komplett anders so ist alles alles
bequem ein beispiel des hauses in china
zu sein
aber dort sie auf jeden fall ist unsere
heimat
das kann man nicht ende
sie leben jetzt in altdorf und erfüllen
die hiesigen normen durchaus in der
schlosserei steine hat pepe eine anlehre
gemacht erzielte mit der note 5,5 das
beste abschluss resultat im ganzen
kanton und macht jetzt noch eine
wichtige lehre sein vater wäre stolz auf
ihn und carlos der romantiker unter den
brüdern lebt in einer neuen beziehung
er ist gerade weil seine freundin
manuela eingezogen
er versucht wir ein leben zwischen den
kontinenten schmackhaft zu machen welch
eine karibik saga bisher dort nahm ich
finde ich einfach nicht
die mutter marina die hier im hotel
höflich gearbeitet hatte ist nicht mehr
da sie tat sich schwer mit der sprache
dem geld den klima als auch für uns die
kinder oder die anfahrt zum 13
die kälte und klima die einfach
schweizer oder viel mut für mutter ist
hält das ist einfach schwierig war es
wichtig soziale kälte oder die
klimatische kälter die deine mutter
ich denke mal die sozial kennt ja das
war ich denke gegen die kälte so winter
so war nicht so ein problem oder die für
das kann man nicht kaufen
er will es einfach die leute oder da hat
man zum beispiel man hat kein nachbar
augen der karibik kommen soll nachbar
gehen
das trinken sie sind einfach ganz anders
da sieht man die nachbarn vielleicht
einmal im monat oder heute plötzlich
wasser zu fällen
sie waren einst auch mit diesem ziel ja
das ja
die firma ruag abteilung recycling
schattdorf hier wo viele sein ende
findet dreschen wie samuel den jüngsten
der brüder wieder
mit den tränen vom zivilisationsmüll
verdient der knapp über 3000 franken
netto pro monat
damit hat er sich ganz gut eingerichtet
denn er der schon immer etwas anders
wahr macht auch jetzt aber es anders aus
seine brüder
er lebt alleine und er hat einen kleinen
hausteil gemietet mitten in outdoor
jetzt will es allen zeigen
all jenen die ihn für zu unbegabt
hielten um im leben wirklich erfolg zu
haben
er ist stolz auf sein kleines reich eine
adrette zweizimmerwohnung für rund 600
franken pro monat
doch seien wirkliche triumph lebt in der
karibik heißt deira und baut zum
hochzeit sein
die schule zusammen
und was die schweiz tun
ich wähle sie hier eine lehre machen und
dann zusammenarbeit und dann einhausen
und gar nicht republik machen so ist der
letzte irgendwie der erste zumindest was
das heiraten betrifft auch in der
freizeit geht es einen eigenen weg her
ist der fitness
er hat seinen eigenen fitness club
sozusagen und nun das nächste kapitel
dieser geschichte karibische heirat
[Musik]
kleider probe da die braut ist zarte 17
jahre hat seit zwei jahren sind sie und
samuel ein paar
hier hat sie begonnen
diese liebesgeschichte im lyzeum branche
lieber wo die braut auch heute noch zur
schule geht ist die schweiz leben mit
dir ich hoffe möglichst bald und was ist
zu tun in der schweiz
ich möchte etwas arbeiten zb als
verkäuferin und sunny so helfen geld zu
verdienen
[Musik]
und später möchten wir dann ein haus
bauen in der karibik und zusammen eine
familie gründen
und paul treffen wir auch marina wieder
die 50 jährige ist wieder glücklich und
sie lebt in rancho arriba auf der
gleichen finger wie damals mit calli wie
gefällt es dir denn wieder hier zu sein
ich bin immer auf einer finca und schaue
hierzu allem zur landwirtschaft zum
garten einen großen unterschied zur
schweiz
in der schweiz war es doch immer nur
arbeit und arbeit und keine möglichkeit
selber etwas anzupflanzen
hier haben wir doch einfach alles was
wir brauchen zusammen mit ihrem freund
manolo führt marina den hofreiter ganz
im geiste des verstorbenen karl mahrer
um marina leben aus klein bauen sie
haben hühner und kühe pflanzen café
mandarinen und bananen
sie sind eigentlich selbst versorgen
erdverbunden
wir leben hier nicht in einer
fantasiewelt wir führen ein richtiges
leben ist denn auch das soziale leben
des hauses schmalz aber klar wir leben
hier mit den geschwistern den eltern und
den freunden kurz vor weihnachten
bescherung auf der finca zwei weitere
söhne marina sind eingetroffen friedrich
und sein bruder pepe und mit ihnen eine
niegelnagelneue waschmaschine sowie ein
kühlschrank eine der schweiz
bist du stolz sein
klar bin ich stolz auf sie und sie auf
mich hoffe ich doch
[Musik]
zu besuch bei sammys schwiegereltern
er gefällt der bräutigam mit schweizer
pass und so bist du zufrieden mit uns
ich weiß dass du ein guter mann für sie
bis ich kannte deinen vater und deine
mutter du kommst aus einer guten familie
und sie da meine tochter habe ich so
erzogen dass sie fleißig ist und eine
gute hausfrau geben wird
[Musik]
die bände
marina was hältst du halten dich von
dieser hochzeit
sollen sie doch heiraten wenn es sein
muss sind sie den zu jüngern sehr jung
er ist doch noch ein baby ach was
beide sind noch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das immer so meister
um standesamt zurück auf die kleine
finca dem dreh und angelpunkt dieser
geschichte samuel hat sich durchgesetzt
samuel der mann so gar nichts zutraute
samuel der letzte von caris söhnen der
nun irgendwie der erste ist
[Musik]
drei monate nach der hochzeit ist nun
auch in der schweiz angekommen und das
wetter präsentiert sich so wie sie es
von den postkarten kennt was sie bisher
nur vom hörensagen kannte gefällt dir
und sie ist überwältigt von all den
neuen eindrücken und dann die ankunft in
sammys kleinem häuschen wo das junge
ehepaar nun wohnen wird sprache
es warten viele anforderungen auf die
junge frauen dieser welt in der alles so
anders ist aus zu hause szenenwechsel in
der zwischenzeit haben carlos und
manuela eine größere wohnung in autos
gefunden und manuela ist glücklich mit
ihrem song ayo der jetzt gerade sechs
monate haut ist aber mittlerweile habe
ich langsam gelegt werden dass es
wirkliche prüfung wenn der afrika sowie
den e mail adresse
wien
carlos arbeitet in einem baugeschäft und
manuela hat eine 30 prozent stelle als
kaufmännische angestellte gefunden
ihre löhne reichen für ein gutes aber
bescheidenes auskommen und die sache
die bessere grundausbildung
gesundheitswesen spitze
aber der wird sich freuen teilt diese
kritik sie ansetzen bevor
zwar kann man sich damals war moni zwei
tage später
man geht jedoch je nach nun weniger
wegen der gefechte hätten den rasch um
konflikte dieser befindet ihr habe zwar
die fleißige täter oder setzt milliarden
stoff konflikte oder stammhalter der
familie feierabend ist der ganze stolz
seiner eltern manuela deutsch pokallos
spanischen liga und kinder zu haben und
das jetzt seit ich finde so sind wir
eigentlich gut wir haben eine schöne
wohnung wurde und nun wieder beruhigt
was tun ja kann man nicht sagen so viel
wie möglich
und so die wir hier leben ja ich will
dich zu sagen es hat vor nachteiligen
schule und so haben sie dabei sehr oder
und sich bei der arbeiten und so weiter
und nun eben wenn ich nachdenke oder das
was ich früher hatte als kind oder wir
fast nur dort kriegen ja was war das ja
man kann sagen wir über einen reich oder
mit nicht mit geld aber sollte es mit
andere sachen
es war eine zeit oder jahres kindheit
ein fan beim vater oder lang heutzutage
schwierig wieder zu haben
zurück im kleinen haus von semi und
deira im zentrum altdorfs
[Musik]
anderthalb jahre ist es nun her dass
tyler in der schweiz angekommen ist sie
ist jetzt 18 jahre alt und ist meistens
zu hause und wartet dort auf sammy der
eine feste anstellung in einem
baugeschäft gefunden hat
[Musik]
das kleine haus liegt gleichsam zwischen
den kontinenten oder eine uhr ist immer
auf die zeit von santo domingo gestellt
jene zeit die für sie die zeit des
herzens geblieben ist
samy kommt wann immer möglich über
mittag nach hause und manchmal hat man
das gefühl die beiden lebten ganz für
sich allein auf ihren eigenen planeten
zweimal pro woche teil 1 der
deutschunterricht sie bemüht sich
redlich und auch semi werden ab und zu
deutsch mit dir doch es ist nicht
einfach
deutsch ist für sie die erste
fremdsprache überhaupt
ich sehe ein kleid wurde das ist eine
sehr gute was sehen sie bei einigen
bällen um ein video oder diese 1
das ist dass das ist das was zählt sind
fast nur leute die spanisch sprechen und
tut sich entsprechend schwer mit der
deutschen sprache
was fehlt dir denn einig hier den
vergleich zur heimat
ich habe dort drüben einfach mehr mehr
freunde als hier
hier habe ich keine wirklich hast du
immer noch keine freunde
auch in der schule nicht doch in der
schule schon aber die sprechen auch kein
spanisch und so habe ich nur eine
freundin die spanisch spricht nur eine
einzige unten im haus der familie
künstlerin früheren befindet sich ein
kleiner coiffeursalon dort kann dann ab
und zu mit hilfen und sogar selber sehr
gut wirklich maxi hat handarbeit frauen
das super sprachbarriere dass sie
wirklich ein problem
die sprache ist natürlich früher mit der
kundschaft
ich glaube war gesamte da geld für
zukäufe ja aber du hast die hand dazu
für seine arbeit
jetzt müssen nur noch deutsch lernen und
dann kannst du könntest du oder eine
alle reden machen
jeweils samstags treffen sich die
feierabend brüder zum domino alle wohnen
in altdorf alle sind sie fleißig und
sparen geld denn alle haben das gleiche
ziel
zu hause in der früheren heimat ein
häuschen zu bauen
pepe macht eine lehre auf metallbauer
und will später polizist werden
freddy arbeitet auf dem bau und hat
dieses jahr die rekrutenschule gemacht 0
carlos ist nicht mehr so oft hier
anzutreffen
seit er vater geworden ist
dafür macht er jetzt ausflüge mit seiner
familie eines ihrer liebsten ziele die
masoala habe im zürcher zoo mit ihrem
tropischen klima
sie führen so etwas wie das leben einer
typischen schweizer kleinfamilie
wenn er hierher komme fühle er sich wie
zu hause ganz beschwingt unzufrieden
sagt carlos wie zu hause in der karibik
geben wird sowie sowieso nicht
doch so ein bisschen heimat
[Musik]
ja
wir haben
[Musik]
und so hat carlos zumindest sind so
einen ausgleich gefunden zwischen seinen
beiden wurzeln die tropen und den alpen
der schweiz und der karibik zwei welten
nahe beieinander und doch weit entfernt
[Musik]